ted cruz takes it on the chin after
traveling to cancun in the middle of the
texas freeze
new studies find that all of american
life has turned political and team biden
promotes endless coveted restrictions
i'm ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro
[Music]
show
today's show is sponsored by expressvpn
protect your data from big tech with the
vpn i trust visit expressvpn.com
slash ben we'll get to all the news in
just one moment first let me remind you
you're spending way too much on your
cell phone bill like a lot too much on
your cell phone bill why well they're
telling you out there you need unlimited
data you don't need limited data
here is what you need what you actually
need is unlimited talk text and six gigs
of data
for just 30 bucks a month you're going
to be saving hundreds of dollars over
the course of the year by shifting
to pure talk usa that's why over a
thousand of you my extremely wise
listeners have made the switch from your
overpriced wireless carrier to pure talk
over the past couple of months
what exactly are the rest of you waiting
for if you're with att verizon or
t-mobile your family could save over 800
a year just by switching to pure talk
you get the same great coverage because
they use the exact same towers as one of
the big carriers
you can even keep your phone and your
number but you will be saving a fortune
by the way pure talk is the top-rated
wireless company by consumer affairs
with the absolute best customer service
team based right here
in america again you get an amazing deal
unlimited talk text and six gigs of data
for over
for just 30 bucks a month and if you go
over on that data they're not going to
charge you for it so what do you have to
lose grab that mobile phone it's all
pound 250 say my name ben shapiro when
you do
you will save fifty percent off your
first month dial pound two five zero say
keyword ben shapiro pure talk usa
simply smarter wireless alrighty so the
big news of the day is that ted cruz
went to cancun
yep that's where we are in american life
so here is what happened
according to the uk daily mail which has
a 59 photo spread i kid you not a 59
photo spread because this is the only
story that the media would like to cover
today
is the fact that senator cruz left texas
and went down to cancun
and then he came back and was super
apologetic about having gone down to
cancun while texas is freezing and
millions of people don't have power
so here is the uk daily mail reporting a
chastened at ted cruz
landed back in houston on thursday
afternoon and said he regrets flying to
cancun in the middle of the state's
energy crisis for a vacation
but insisted he was just trying to be a
dad cruz enraged his state by fleeing in
the midst of the worst snowstorms to hit
in decades with the power failing for
millions and people left freezing in the
subzero temperatures at least 24 people
are known to have died in texas
cruz claims his 10 and 12 year old
daughters asked him on wednesday if they
could go on vacation to mexico with
their friends so he and his wife
boarded a plane hours later it was
obviously a mistake in hindsight i would
not have done it he said speaking on
arrival
at his home in houston here is what cruz
had to say
justifying why he had gone to cancun in
the first place
well texas is going through horrific
storms
and millions of texans have lost power
and lost peace
and have been hurt and
our family was among them we had no heat
no power
and yesterday my daughters asked
if they could take a trip with some
friends and
heidi and i agreed so i flew down with
them last night
dropped them off here and now i'm headed
back to texas and
back to continuing to work to try to get
the power of what's happening in texas
is unacceptable that a lot of texans are
hurting
okay so a few things that are worth
noting right off the bat obviously
horrifying optics right the worst optics
because rule number one of politics in
today's day and age
is that you have to appear on the scene
whenever there is something bad that
happens now
i'll be honest with you i've never been
a big fan of this rule i think this rule
is kind of dumb
i i always thought that it was
ridiculous that people were upset with
for example george w bush for not
landing on the ground during hurricane
katrina
like okay so now he's looking at the
water great right by the way
barack obama during the last louisiana
hurricane in 2016.
barack obama stayed up in martha's
vineyard for much of that in fact donald
trump took advantage of that in the 2016
campaign he himself flew down
to louisiana but you know like
politicians
they obviously a lot of the job is
optics a lot of the job is appearing to
be sympathetic or be compassionate and
cruz failed here
no question right which i think cruz
himself would acknowledge at this point
but this is like the most obvious
political move of all time you can't jet
off to cancun if you want to send your
wife and your kids go ahead and send
your wife and your kids you got to stay
there
obviously okay that is number one and
it's perfectly obvious and it is
perfectly true
that it was a horrible move by cruz not
to stick around
in texas okay all of that happens to be
true
the amount of attention the media are
paying to this is overwhelming and kind
of insane
kind of insane i mean they tracked down
like every aspect of this so much so
that the new york times uncovered texts
between heidi cruz ted's wife
and the neighbors so i guess that we are
done with the whole you're not allowed
to access
texts without people's permission
routine i guess we're done with that
whole thing
because it was a group text and somebody
gave it to the new york times so that's
okay now right so
hunter biden's computer twitter had to
shut down the entire new york post
account
for putting out information based on
hunter biden's laptop even though
there was no legal barrier to that
information actually being put out there
here apparently it's totally okay to
start leaking people's
texts that are directed at friends by
the way these friends are jerks i'm just
gonna say that
so apparently here is what happened
according to the new york times
like millions of his constituents across
texas senator ted cruz had a frigid home
without electricity this week amid the
state's power crisis but unlike most mr
cruz got out
fleeing houston and hopping a wednesday
afternoon flight to cancun with his
family for a respite at a luxury resort
photos of mr cruz and his wife heidi
boarding the flight ricocheted quickly
across social media and left both his
political allies and rivals aghast
at a tropical trip as the disaster
unfolded at home the blowback only
intensified after cruz a republican
released a statement saying he had flown
to mexico to be a good dad and accompany
his daughters and their friends
which of course is never a good look
saying that that your your kids are the
reason that you did
acts is never a particularly good look
although i will acknowledge there are
folks on the left being like why would
you ever take advice from your kids the
same people who think a three-year-old
should decide their gender in any case
text messages sent from miss cruz to
friends and houston neighbors on
wednesday revealed a hastily planned
trip
their house was freezing as miss cruz
put it and she proposed to get away
until sunday
ms cruz invited others to join them at
the ritz carlton in cancun where they
had stayed many times
noting the room price this week 309
bucks a night and it's good security
the text messages were provided to the
new york times and confirmed by a second
person on the thread
who declined to be identified because of
the private nature of the tax
okay so let me just say this uh whoever
was deleting this and then confirming it
to the times
jackass like seriously like nasty thing
to do
but put all that aside again is it a
smart political move to jet set off to
cancun in the middle
of a freezing winter obviously bad
optics and politics
is half the optics game that is a
reality now
something is obviously true here and
that is that the media's attempt to
paint this
as the greatest act of political
hypocrisy in modern american history is
absurd on its face
absolutely absurd on its face
let me give you say four examples of
hypocrisy
in the last year okay so example number
one of hypocrisy andrew cuomo declaring
himself an unbelievably great leader
like such a great leader that he won an
emmy
people declaring him the greatest leader
of all time chris cuomo going on tv with
him and making jokes with him every
night cnn waving its own conflict of
interest rules so that they could do
that
little comedy routine andrew cuomo being
praised to the skies by dr anthony fauci
and it turns out he was lying to his own
party and to the public and to the
families of people who died of covet by
suggesting that the death count that the
death count in nursing homes was
significantly lower than it actually was
which may in fact be a criminal act and
now he's under investigation okay so
that's active
political hypocrisy number one declaring
yourself a leader while simultaneously
avoiding
the cost of leadership by failing to
take responsibility for your own
policies
and that's hypocrisy because you have
said essentially that your standard
is a standard that applies to no one
else you can lie and you can cheat and
you can
lie about people dying and that's
totally okay so that is
hypocrisy number one okay that's example
of hypocrisy number one
hypocrisy example number two nancy
pelosi is very much in favor of
lockdowns the entire city of san
francisco is locked down and nancy
pelosi waves the rules for herself to go
indoors and get her hair did
right that is example if hypocrisy
number two because nancy pelosi was an
advocate for many of the rules she was
then breaking herself
in order to be a hypocrite you have to
be an advocate for a rule and then
you have to violate that rule right so
nancy pelosi violates that rule
hey similar sort of example gavin newsom
very much a friend a very much a fan
gavin newsom
of the lockdown rules across the state
of california small businesses being
forcibly shut people being put out of
work because gavin newsom will not allow
them to open their businesses even if
they are trying to do so
in safe and secure fashion and then
governor gavin newsom heads on over to
the french laundry
right that is another example of
political hypocrisy and we saw lots of
examples that look exactly like that one
right you had
the the mayor of i'm trying to remember
which texas city
heading on over to cabo it was different
than cruz
because he was actively advocating that
people not travel while traveling
okay so we'll get to cruz in a second
because cruz this isn't
it's a bad politically it's a bad
political move optically
it is not actually hypocrisy in order to
be hypocrisy cruz would have had to do
something that he advocated for no one
else
but that's not actually what cruz did
here cruz again
being politically foolish here and uh
optically ridiculous and all of that and
he's paying the price for it today
it's not actually even close to the
level of these other folks he did not
advocate for texas freezing over
he did not advocate for people to be
trapped in their homes
he's not somebody who's like you know
what it'll be great if you stay at home
in the middle of this phrase i'm taking
off
and he hit if everybody could get out
presumably he'd be in favor of everybody
heading on over
to cancun so again politically tone deaf
on an extraordinary level for sure
and he will pay the price for that but
the media are treating the cruise
incident as significantly worse than any
of the other incidents
in order for you to be a true hypocrite
you have to actually
foster support for a rule yeah or in
many of these cases
implement a rule yourself and then not
abide by the rule
right you have to be a governor who
advocates for a lockdown and then you
break the lockdown you have to be a
mayor like lori lightfoot who says don't
go out and get your hair done
and then go out and get your hair done
right that is an act of political
hypocrisy it's locking down people when
they don't want to be locked down and
then you don't have to lock down because
you're the special
okay that's not what cruz did here for
the one thousand time
two things can be true at once
politically tone deaf not nearly
meritorious of the kind of
media coverage that is currently being
provided with regard to cruz it is
blanket
and it is overwhelming and these major
newspapers have dedicated reporters to
checking on ted cruz's dog
okay the blowback from this on the right
is probably not going to be against cruz
frankly
over the course of time because the
media always over the overplay their
hand they can't just say this is
politically stupid and it shows that
he's uncompassionate or that he's out of
touch
all of which you can make the case based
on this particular incident right
but instead they're going so far that
they're being like what a hypocrite what
a terrible person
there's a piece over at the atlantic
talking about what an awful human being
ted cruz is because he jet set it off to
cancun
right david graham at the atlantic has
an entire piece titled ted cruz is no
hypocrite he's worse he's worse than a
hypocrite
and we'll get to more on this in just
one second first let's talk about
something you can do
for the country so we can all feel it a
lot of the american values that we
cherish
are slipping away the left is winning
victory after cultural victory
it's time to fight back my friends over
at the prager university foundation
better known as prageru it's a
non-profit media powerhouse several of
us here at the daily wire are featured
in prageru videos
prageru knows how to reach millions of
young people online like no other
non-profit young people aren't hearing
the reasons that america is great
they aren't learning about our values
prageru is addressing that head on
if you want to help save america go to
prageru.com forward slash daily wire
prageru's videos are watched 4 million
times every single day
more than 70 percent of viewers say
their minds were changed after watching
and
more than 60 percent of those viewers
are young prageru is also leading the
charge against big tech censorship
fighting for our voices to be heard far
and wide prageru is on the front lines
of the culture war every single day
now they need you to help supply the
fight if you want to be sure that your
donation dollars are going to be used to
support your values donate to prageru
today at prageru.com
daily wire program is fantastic i've
done several videos with them they
really are focused on
getting people the information they need
in basically five minutes or under
it's they create fantastic material
viewed by at this point
hundreds of millions of people it's
really really worthwhile go check out
prageru.com
dailywire and donate i promise you it is
a charitable donation well worth your
time and effort okay so
as i say the media's attention on the
ted cruz jaunt
is absolutely overwhelming 59 pictures
59 pictures from the uk
daily mail okay the new york times
dedicated
an entire report to the text messages
between heidi cruz
and friends right cruz told the
television crew at the cancun airport
what's happening in texas is
unacceptable he was wearing a texas
state flag mask and a short sleeve
publisher tucked into jeans the
temperature in cancun was above 80
degrees fahrenheit on thursday
and in the 30s in houston and then when
he came back to the united states cruz
offered a new statement
with a different tone when he had tried
to explain the vacation without regrets
speaking to reporters after his arrival
home he conceded the trip was obviously
a mistake said he had begun having
second thoughts as soon as he boarded
the plane to mexico intent
on a few days of remote work in the sun
he said the plan had been to state
through the weekend with the family
that changes from his original statement
where he said that he was going to go
there drop the kids and come back
he said on the one hand all of us our
parents have a responsibility to take
care of our kids take care of our
families i also have a responsibility i
take very seriously of fighting for the
state of texas
as it became a bigger and bigger
firestorm it became all the more
compelling
that i needed to come back and of course
this trended on social media you got
flying ted which of course is a play on
trump's nickname for for cruz
lion's head he got fled cruz which fox
news
used the democratic
texas party chairman said this is about
as callous as any politician can get
he's a politician that has really never
cared much about anybody but himself and
of course
that criticism is going to stick with
regard to cruz because
you can make that case but the media are
going further
the media are going further and they are
suggesting that this thing not only
ought to be national news for a day
but it's it's like the worst thing that
has ever happened in the history of
mankind
okay believe it or not reporters were
deployed
to ted cruz's house to check on his
poodle i kid you not
apparently snowflake that's the name of
his dog was spotted by a reporter at 1pm
on thursday looking out the front door
a security guard stationed outside the
property said he had been tasked with
feeding and tending to the dog
in the freezing home the dog was adopted
by the family as a puppy
in 2014. so
much of this is just you know people
hate cruz and this is a great
great way to dunk on ted cruz
but the way that this is being played in
the media is that this is some some sort
of
referendum on republican policy in some
way
which is weird because what the hell
does this have to do with policy again
it has to do with the politician making
an absolutely bad tone of
optical decision what does it have to do
with policy per se
i think the answer here is pretty
obvious not much but that's not stopping
the media from again going too far
again i give all those examples of
hypocrisy if you're going to rank those
examples of hypocrisy and how much
attention they deserve it'll go cuomo
number one with a bullet right i mean
cuomo was treated as the
greatest governor in the history of
planet earth and it turns out that he
was lying to people
open now he was not just lying to people
openly and by the way we knew that since
may the media just
just decided not to cover it until after
the election
he was actively threatening other
members of the new york
democratic party for example new york
democratic assemblyman ron kim
he came out yesterday and he was like
you know what my family was absolutely
terrified
of cuomo like if you're going to talk
about the disparity in coverage
most of the major networks last night
carried blanket coverage for ted cruz
going to cancun
how many of them have ever had blanket
coverage for andrew cuomo the sitting
governor
of new york actively lying about how
many people died in nursing homes
because of his crappy coveted policy
and actively threatening other members
of the democratic party which one of
those is a bigger story just
on pure objective level one might be
more fun to meme
one might be more fun to dunk on but
it's pretty obvious which one of these
is a bigger story the media should be
paying attention to here is new york
democratic assemblyman ron kim
explaining that the sitting governor of
new york the greatest of all governors
in the history of the world was actively
threatening him
governor cuomo called me the late the
next day at 8pm
while i was about to bait my kids i was
with my wife and for 10 minutes
he berated me uh he yelled at me he told
me that
you know my career will be over he's
been biting his tongue for months
against me
it was loud enough for my wife to hear
and i tried to show her
but she was in shock i mean she didn't
get any sleep that night
and we were terrified and you know she
left
he left a shocking moment
for all of us in our family okay but um
that's not
nearly as worthy of coverage as the fact
that uh senator cruz
threatened no one went to cancun and
then came back
again not a justification for the optics
this is not what about ism
this is a pure referendum on how crappy
the media are at their jobs
in one case you haven't a governor
actively lying about how many people
died in his state because of his policy
and threatening members of his own party
and the media are like
well you know it's a story we'll do a
little coverage i guess we gotta cover
it
and on the other hand you have a
republican senator in texas in the
middle of a freeze that he's not
responsible for
also by the way not a state official
he's not the governor of texas he's not
the houston
he's not the mayor of houston he did
what he was supposed to do as a senator
in the sense that he not not flying he
did what he was supposed to do in terms
of policy by contacting the white house
and asking for a federal emergency
declaration
which was then received biden put one
out okay
that is not even close to on par with
even the active
hypocrisy of like gavin newsom who is
actively promulgating a policy that he
himself was not abiding by
cruz is not responsible for the freeze
cruz is not responsible for going and
thawing the pipelines
cruz is a senator he's responsible for
the political dumbassery of not heading
on to
heading over to a local church and
handing out blankets or something the
way the beta o'rourke is
like o'rourke at least understands that
side of the business he also understands
how to skateboard
but you know you're responsible for that
for sure but that is not on the same
power i mean again bill de blasio the
mayor of new york was ripping into cuomo
yesterday
how is it not a bigger story that the
mayor of new york is ripping into the
governor of new york for being a liar
and an authoritarian
it's a sad thing to say mika but that's
classic andrew cuomo
a lot of people in new york state have
received those phone calls
you know the bullying is nothing new
i believe ron kim and it's very very sad
no public servant
no person who's uh telling the truth
should be treated that way
um but yeah that the the threats
the the belittling uh the demand that
someone changed their statement
right that moment uh many many times
i've heard that and i know a lot of
other people in this state have heard
that
remember this is not a big story what's
a big story is that ted cruz went down
to cancun with his daughters and then
came back
that's the big story here politically
tone deaf not hypocrisy
and not really having anything to do
with policy doesn't matter
doesn't matter you've seen the media
completely reverse that of course
we'll get some more of this in just one
second first let's talk
about the expensive fitness bikes that
you are seeing you know like right now
is a great time to have a great fitness
bike at home and you see these things
like peloton you're like wow that looks
kind of cool
but then you look at the price like whoa
and all your hair falls out
well what if you could get something
that is just the same quality
as amazing classes and it's going to
cost you like a fraction of that
this is where echelon comes in when it
comes to getting or staying in shape
nothing feels as good as that feeling of
accomplishment of hitting your fitness
goals and feeling great about yourself
echelon can get you there echelon offers
the next generation of connected fitness
bikes fitness mirrors rowing machines
and their echelon stride
smart treadmill no matter what your
favorite fitness activity echelon gives
you a fun and challenging workout from
the comfort of your home
the ex-7s is echelon's latest
state-of-the-art innovation it takes
cycling to the next level
the x7s is connected bike it's built
with performance flexibility and
durability in mind
it's the bike for competitors at heart
their world-class instructors will
motivate you with thousands of daily
live and on-demand studio level classes
always available when you need them
unlike their competitors echelon is
affordable for everyone
and one membership lets up to five
family members all work out at the same
time right now
you can try any echelon fitness
equipment at home for 30 days
this is great i mean during the pandemic
tons of people have taken up these sorts
of courses but they've been paying way
too much instead
you need to check out echelon right now
head on over to
that is echelonfit.com fit dot com
slash ben go check them out right now so
the atlantic of course tries to go too
far there's an entire piece saying that
ted cruz is worse than a hypocrite
according to david graham
why well because ted cruz
backs libertarian energy policy and that
means that he's really bad
according to david graham cruz's
approach to politics and texas's
approach to electrical generation
flow from the same libertarian-inflected
low-regulation small government vision
in this world view the government's role
is to set a minimal baseline requirement
offer market-based incentives to ensure
they work and then stay the hell out of
the way
consider how this works out in the case
of electricity the lower 48 u.s states
are divided into two big electrical
grids except for texas which maintains
its own independent system
the state maintains a separate grid to
avoid having to comply with federal
regulation
if texas had been connected to the
broader national grid the state might
have been able to borrow power that
would have filled the hole left when the
large parts of the system failed in the
storm
instead texas has experiencing has
experienced staggering
blackouts okay what in the world does
this have to do with ted cruz going down
to cancun
ted cruz is not in favor of people
living without electricity
so what in the world like seriously
so basically it's ted cruz went to
cancun therefore all republican policy
is bad same thing in politico the
swaggering texas brand of free market
governance that's central to the state's
political identity
is taking a beating according to mark
caputo so ted cruz goes
down to cancun and the answer is you
know we need more regulation what
like what do these have to do with one
another seriously there's a far better
case than what texas really needs is
less investment in wind and solar and
more investment in nuclear energy
there's a strong case to be made for
that but i don't know what any of that
has to do with ted cruz going to cancun
why can't we keep these things separate
because people in the media do not want
these things to be separate that is the
answer
people in the media wish to lump
everything together as always because
when it comes to the media narrative
understand the antecedent
in any if then statement does not matter
only
only the consequence matters if x
then we should follow democratic policy
it doesn't matter what x is it could be
literally anything
if ted cruz goes to cancun then we
should follow democratic policy
if there's a big texas freeze then we
if florida and california have
completely differing coveted policies
that end with similar numbers of deaths
despite the fact that florida didn't
wreck its economy and has more old
people
then we should follow democratic policy
right it doesn't matter what the
antecedent is
the end of the statement will always be
exactly the same so every time a
republican does something
that is dumb this becomes an example of
why republican policy is bad in the
extreme
now i can much more easily make the case
that when
gavin newsom violates his own strictures
then
maybe the strictures are bad because
he's not even living by them
i can make the case that when andrew
cuomo lies about his own policy
maybe that's because his policy was bad
you can see the connection between the
antecedent the if
in the statement and the then in the
statement before the media there is no
connection it's just about hey we can
dunk on ted cruz and since we're dunking
on ted cruz and we don't like ted cruz
and
it's fun to dunk on ted cruz that means
that texas energy policy
is super bad and you should vote for
democrats not because
you should get rid of cruz right you
should vote for democrats across the
board
you should vote against john cornyn you
should vote against greg abbott you
should vote against dan crenshaw like
every republican
again you can make a savvy political
case that cruz is going to face some
really tough sledding in the next texas
election
because of this specifically but it's
going to be hard to make the case that
every republican ought to pay the brunt
because ted cruz went to cancun or
something that's a very very silly
argument
okay meanwhile coveted policy continues
to be a complete mess from the biden
administration how much of a mess
is coveted policy from the biden
administration so
there is a there is a piece in politico
talking about joe biden's
joe biden's failures with regard to cove
right he has not answered when we can
take the mask off he has not answered
when we are going to be able to go back
to normal he has suggested maybe we're
going to have to do it till next year
he has he's put out bad information
about
hurt immunity he has suggested that
schools don't need to reopen and then
they should reopen but they can only
reopen part-time but they should reopen
full-time
and we should have ventilation and
masking and facts and it's all a mess
it's all a complete mess
and they keep shifting the timeline over
and over so here's politico's answer to
that the real problem
the real problem for joe biden is that
you know
the reality is that reality is hard man
and joe biden is just running up against
reality so you never heard this kind of
throat clearing when it came to donald
trump when it was donald trump and he
was president then it was every single
death
is to be placed at donald trump's
doorstep here is how political opens the
story on biden's
completely mishka bobbled coveted policy
quote president joe biden's presidency
hinges
in large part on his success in handling
the pandemic but nearly a month into
power he's beginning to discover just
how much of that task is out of his
control
oh you see it's not that he's blowing it
and it's not that he's bad at this
and it's not that it's mishka bobbled
it's that it's just out of his control
guys i mean you can't blame the old
sucker
i mean why exactly would you think that
it was in his control in the first place
so after a year of everything that goes
wrong is donald trump's fault up to and
including
a crazy lady in arizona feeding her
husband fish tank cleaner
and him dying of it everything is
trump's fault every single thing
because the buck stops here now biden's
in office and we're like a month in
and politico's like well you know a lot
of things aren't in his control guys i
mean can we really blame him
the white house is locked in a delicate
dance with governors over reopening
schools
distributing covet shots and enforcing
mass mandates with biden's team wary of
alienating key state leaders
even as it takes stock of the lurching
response to the crisis governors in turn
are starting to push back on the first
federal efforts to pressure them
the administration is poor to energy
into courting both democrats and
republicans pitching itself as an equal
partner an eager collaborator it's a
sharp contrast from the trump era when
most decisions were thrown to the states
yes because most decisions should be
done at the state level
if it had been up to biden florida would
have been locked down like california
not the opposite
this whole time governors have felt like
they're the ones under the guns had one
advisor to several governors they
understand the way this has been set up
people are inclined to blame them if
things don't go well
yet the federal government's charm
offensive threatens to bog down biden's
early efforts to reign in the virus
and claim political credit for restoring
a sense of normalcy
yeah you know it's tough being biden the
angle of these articles is so
great i mean it's so perfectly
predictable everything donald trump did
was super duper duper terrible on every
possible level not just the bad stuff
all of the stuff
everything joe biden does that's
incompetent and bad by the way where is
joe biden in the middle of all this
texas freeze
he called a lid yesterday at like 8 a.m
his campaign has just continued meaning
he's just asleep
he's just watching matlock all day
so whatever it's all wild meanwhile his
administration continues to be a
complete mess
when it comes to exactly how to treat
covet so dr anthony fauci the greatest
of all doctors except for dr joel biden
he is now saying maybe we'll get back to
normal in fall or winter
in fall or winter okay now in a second
i'm gonna explain why this is crazy why
we should be back to normal essentially
by summer
but here is dr anthony fauci saying
maybe fall maybe winter maybe never
here's dr fauci the greatest of all
doctors sexiest man alive
dr anthony fauci if you're going to ask
is what about getting back to a
situation
where you can have theaters that might
be able to have
below capacity that restaurants indoor
dining can be happening but with
moderately diminished
capacity that's going to be somewhere
between the fall and the end of the year
if you say no no wait a minute i really
want to know
when it's going to get to us close to
normal that you almost don't know the
difference
between what it was before maybe you're
gonna still have to wear masks
that likely will be as the president
said by the end of the year by
christmas maybe you'll still have to
wear masks by christmas
no here's my answer no
no no once there is widespread
vaccination the masks are coming off
we're all going to ball games
if you don't want to do that stay home
really stay home at that point
if you're so scared of your own shadow
that after people who are vulnerable
have taken a vaccine
that creates 95 immunity
for a disease that for people under the
age of 65
still was going to kill about five in 1
000 people
who actually got it and now you have 95
immunity
from that five which means according to
my mathematical calculations you are now
down to
0.5 out of 1 000 and you're still
staying home
uh okay at that point it's on you man i
got nothing for you
really nothing now by the way this is
all very silly because the reality is
according to dr marty mccary who's been
a frequent guest on this program
from johns hopkins university he's a
professor over there
at the school of medicine he has an
article in the wall street journal
pointing out that covet cases have
dropped 77 percent
in six weeks according dr mccary we're
gonna have heard immunity by april
by april he says amid the dire coveted
warnings one crucial fact has been
largely ignored
cases are down 77 over the past six
weeks if a medication slash
cases by 77 we'd call it a miracle pill
why is the number of cases plummeting
much faster than experts predicted
in large part because natural immunity
from prior infection is far more common
than can be measured by testing
testing has been capturing only from 10
to 25 percent of infections
depending on when the pandemic someone
got the virus applying a time-weighted
case capture average of one in 6.5 to
the cumulative
28 million confirmed cases would mean
about 55 percent of americans already
have natural immunity
now add people getting vaccinated as of
this week 15 percent of americans have
received the vaccine
the figure is rising fast former food
and drug commissioner scott gottlieb
estimates 250 million doses will have
been delivered to some 150 million
people by the end of march
says dr makari there is reason to think
the country is racing toward an
extremely low level of infection
as more people have been infected most
of whom have mild or no symptoms there
are fewer americans left to be
infected at the current trajectory i
expect covert will be mostly gone by
april allowing americans to resume
normal life he says the antibodies
studies almost certainly underestimate
natural immunity antibody testing
doesn't capture antigen-specific t cells
which develop memory once they are
activated by the virus
survivors of the 1918 spanish flu were
found in 2008
90 years later to have memory cells
still able to produce neutralizing
antibodies
researchers at sweden's karolinska
institute found the percentage of people
mounting a t-cell response after mild or
asymptomatic coping 19 infection
consistently exceeded the percentage
with detectable antibodies
coveted 19 deaths in the united states
would also suggest much broader immunity
than recognized about 1 in 600 americans
has died of cova-19 which translates to
a population fatality rate of about 0.15
percent
the covet 19 infection fatality rate is
about 0.23 percent
these numbers indicate that roughly
two-thirds of the us population has had
the infection
in my own conversations with medical
experts says dr makari i've noticed they
too often dismiss natural immunity
arguing we don't have the data the data
certainly doesn't fit the classic
randomized control trial model of the
old guard medical establishment there's
no control group
but the observational data is compelling
he says that his prediction that coveted
will basically be gone by april
is based on lab data mathematical data
published literature and conversation
with experts it's also based on direct
observation of how hard testing has been
to get especially for the poor
if you live in a wealthy community we're
worried people are vigilant about
getting tested
you might think most infections are
captured by testing if you've seen the
many barriers for testing to low-income
americans
you might think very few infections have
been captured keep in mind most
infections are asymptomatic which still
triggers
natural immunity as makari points out
her immunity has been well documented in
the brazilian city of manaus
where researchers in the lancet reported
the prevalence of covenanting infection
to be 76
resulting in a significant slowing of
the infection
so basically what he's saying is there's
a lot of public pressure not to talk
about hurt immunity because people freak
out
but the reality is we are almost there
we are almost there but notice democrats
are not enthusiastic about talking about
us being almost there
nancy pelosi is out there saying maybe
even after mass vaccination we still
won't reopen
okay at this point you gotta say these
people love the they love the control
they love the control at the beginning
of this pandemic i thought it was
completely fair to talk about lockdowns
i talked about it on the show right
slowing the spread maintenance i
explained it on the program
one of the things i said is the problem
with slowing the spread now
is that there will be widespread spread
later which of course was true
but once it became clear the trajectory
of the virus and how it acted
it has become clearer and clearer and
the way the democrats acted about this
i was living in l.a where we were locked
down i mean locked down
tight welded in our homes i mean you
couldn't go out to a park they shut down
parks
they took yellow tape and put it around
parks they shut down beaches
they shut down hiking trails in l.a and
then
the minute the george floyd protest
started then it was like okay everybody
on the street let's party and i was like
okay at this point it's perfectly
obvious that you guys are not serious
about this
i'm sorry nancy pelosi and crew are not
serious about this here's nancy pelosi
being so serious serious as a heart
attack she says maybe we won't even
reopen
after the vaccinations yeah at this
point gfy
the important point to make on this is
where there is a high incidence
of um of of
covid most of those schools are virtual
or hybrid
anyway they're not uh actual
they're not actual and the vaccination
might not make it
actual anyway so again there has to be a
judgment made
from the community as to how they go
forward
oh well you know that's okay well i
guess that if she says so
if medical expert nancy pelosi says that
vaccination really does nothing
they're trying it's unbelievable you're
trying to get people to take the vaccine
right now and then you are
simultaneously telling them that even
after mass vaccination
and herd immunity we're still going to
be wearing mass in december
absolutely asinine the dumbest thing in
the world even if you don't believe it
and we know that dr fauci is fond of
telling the noble lie right i mean he
said that he told people
wrongly he lied to them he said masks
don't do anything because he wanted to
make sure
that only medical workers got the ppe
remember this
but if dr fauci is fond of telling the
noble lie even if he doesn't believe
that we'll be back to normal by summer
if we all get the vaccine shouldn't he
be saying it
by the way he'd be more medically
correct than he is right now when he's
saying that we're going to be
december january of next year before we
take off the mask that ain't happening
it is not happening okay i can see human
behavior
we're in a free state here in florida
and you can see people who have had
vaccines they're not going to want to
wear that mask for much longer
you can see that people who have had the
disease and they've recovered and
they're okay
they're not going to want to do this for
much longer people want to go back to
their regular lives i know democrats
don't
apparently but there are lots of people
who do and if you don't like it you're
going to have to just
get out of the way nonetheless the
desire for control is astonishing
representative katie porter from
california she says listen
we can't put kids back in school we just
can't i mean sure all the data says we
can but we can't
what's gonna happen when they do all go
back to school and that's where senator
michael bennett from colorado and i have
authored a letter to the department of
education
pointing out to them that we can't just
put kids back in school
as if their learning and social and
emotional development has not been
severely interrupted
and this problem is particularly acute
with regard to math and science
education so it's a workforce issue
amazing and we can't just go back to
school ever
yep no it's not about control though
they're all about the science over here
they're all about the signs meanwhile
they'll send their kids to private
school
that would be hypocrisy as long as we
were talking about the politics of
hypocrisy okay in just a second
we are going to get to a fascinating
article in reason magazine talking about
how the country is polarizing
on every line i mean like consistently
first
reminder last friday we announced a
partnership with canceled star wars
actress gina carano to produce an
upcoming film exclusively for daily wear
members
gina if you're unaware was the star of
the hit disney plus star wars show the
mandalorian
was dropped from the series and by her
talent agency after a series of social
media posts
criticizing the woke mob within hours of
us making that announcement the news
went absolutely viral from usa today
to the la times whether it was shock or
outrage there was a massive show of
coverage in fact
right now on imdb the most popular
actress in america is gina carano
headline after headline documented
gina's rejection of canceled culture it
was a brave
it was a ballsy move in this week's
edition of sunday special we are going
to bring you gina's side of the story in
her first sit-down interview since
getting cancelled she's been smeared by
some of the most powerful people in
hollywood
now it's time for gina to set the record
straight be sure to tune in to the
sunday special at dailywire.com or
youtube this weekend
to get the full story our interview with
gina and the movie deal it's more than a
statement it is fighting back against
the
totalitarian authoritarian woke mob and
the leftist narrative that has dominated
our culture for so long
in gina's own words they cannot cancel
us if we don't let them
and we're not going to let them that's
why we've entered the entertainment
space that's why we need
your help to reclaim the culture go to
dailywire.com
subscribe use cogina to get 25 off your
membership today that is at gina to get
off we are stoked for all the
entertainment content we are about to
present it to you we want you to be a
part of it
and disney plus they got eight billion
dollars we have you we need your support
go to dailywire.com
subscribe use cogina for excellent
content and to be part of the fight and
again use coaching to get 25
off you're listening to the largest
fastest growing conservative podcast and
radio show in the nation
so meanwhile it is important to note
that
politics is indeed ruining everything i
think this is the biggest problem
in the country today really right now is
that politics has infused every aspect
of our life there is nothing in our
lives that is not political
and something that you saw with gina
carano you can't even watch an
entertainment show now
without having to think about politics
you saw this with sports
this is having a dramatic impact on the
social fabric it's something i've been
talking about for a very long time
it is very very bad for the country and
the left has wanted for a long time ever
since the 60s when the left declared
that the personal is political
meaning that whatever you do in your
personal life is actively a
a political move right your sex life is
political what you shop for
is political where he went to school is
political what this leads to
is identity groups based on politics and
those identity groups
are feel threatened the moment somebody
disagrees with them that leads to its
hearing a part of the culture see here's
the thing
normally an identity group is rooted in
immutable characteristics
right being black is being in an
identity group at the very least because
if somebody attacks
the color of your skin that is an attack
on an immutable characteristic shared by
millions of other people
if somebody attacks your politics that
is not an identity group
right politics as an identity group is
mutable you can shift your politics
people do it all the time
so there is a difference between
attacking somebody for race and
attacking someone for politics but the
problem is
once you make politics your identity and
that identity is expressed
in a wide variety of ways across all of
american life what you end up with
is a mathematics whereby where you shop
is political and if i don't shop at your
store this means i'm insulting you and
i'm offending you and i've done
something wrong to you as a human being
reason magazine has a great piece out
today by j.d cecile
titled politics is seeping into our
daily life and ruining everything he
runs down
some of the data on this point according
to a new paper in the journal of public
policy and marketing
by researchers from arizona state
university the university of wyoming and
four other u.s universities
political polarization is having
far-reaching impacts on american life
harming consumer welfare and creating
challenges for people ranging from
elected officials and policy makers to
corporate executives and marketers
the researchers find that people's
chosen political identities become
self-reinforcing
through associations with groups with
shared beliefs our associations can even
create a group shared specific reality
that makes it harder to relate to those
with opposing views
according to the researchers as society
has become increasingly polarized
politicians objectives diverge and their
animosity toward the opposition grows
thereby reducing opportunity for
compromise
partisan incivility is a major reason
for failed dialogue uncivil exchanges
result in disagreement and greater
polarization regardless of the evidence
presented according to reason
people's partisan identities influence
the range of people with whom they're
willing to have relationships
the brands they purchase and the jobs
they take in an era of public health
concerns people choose positions on
matters like vaccines or mass squaring
not based on rational assessment of the
issues but on a plug-and-play adoption
of their tribes at stances
the researchers say with political
positions influencing decisions people
may sacrifice wages lose out on jobs
make sub up sub-optimal purchases
and disregard opportunities to save for
example research has found that
employees accept lower wages to work for
politically like-minded entities
and people may select higher-priced
products or ones that offer less
functional value
polarization has the potential to
prevent neighbors or colleagues of
opposing parties from developing
friendships
this ultimately deprives individuals of
intellectual diversity among other
things
now this all builds on a mountain of
data there is a 2018 survey that found
that nearly two-thirds of consumers
around the world will either buy or
boycott a brand
solely because of its position on a
social or political issue
in the united states that number was 59
percent in 2020 there was another survey
it reported
that 83 percent of millennials find it
important for the companies they buy
from
full line with their values which means
that the price
and quality of the products is actually
secondary which is a problem
in the marketplace if you want better
things you need competition in the
marketplace
not based on the politics of the
corporation but instead based on the
quality of the product that's how we all
get better products
the reason you get new iphones every
couple years is because
android is on their tail but if you've
decided that you don't like the politics
and android as you're always gonna buy
the iphone well that just means that you
are providing a base
for a company that no longer has to
innovate christine morman wrote for
forbes these leaders hope their
political activism will help shape
public opinion and potentially lead to
lasting change while simultaneously
cementing their reputations as moral
leaders or change agents
since then the trend has only
intensified recent events accelerate a
broader movement in business to address
social and political issues according to
a piece in the wall street journal from
january pennsylvania state university
daniel
professor daniel delaposta asked in a
study published in june 2020
what if polarization is less like a
fence getting taller over time and more
like an oil spill that spreads from its
source to gradually attain more and more
previously apolitical attitudes
opinions and preferences even many
initially apolitical lifestyle
characteristics from musical taste to
belief in astrology
can become politicized as signals for
deeper beliefs and preferences
a tendency most saliently captured in
the popular image of the latte liberal
it also happens to be that when you do
all of this what you do is make american
life worse because there is no
common way that we can share anything if
i share a product with somebody i have
now poisoned the product
this happens regularly by the way
there's a survey that was done fairly
recently
in which from harvard business review i
believe it's 2018
and they created essentially a focus
group
and the focus group was made up of
conservatives and liberals and people in
between
and the focus group examined two
companies
one company well actually three one was
a company it's just called
you know generic corp and generic corp
had no politics
and they asked people what they thought
of generic corp and turns out people
were okay with generic corp it was fine
then generic corp identified as a
liberal organization
and the numbers were exactly the same
people were like okay we're fine with
that that's cool
then generic corp identified in this
study as a conservative organization
and its public perception dropped 33
points
33 points obviously that was all
liberals and leftists
who decided that they hated this
corporation they understand that the
default
is that corporations are liberal this is
the thing about renormalization of
american politics i've talked about this
at length and this is really what reason
is talking about
the renormalization of american politics
happens when one intransigent group of
people
decide that they are not going to go
along with commonly held beliefs
and they cuddle everybody else into
silence they emotionally blackmail
everybody else
the left is the only group in america
right now that feels comfortable
in terms of our public daily life
they're the only group of people who
feel comfortable
polls show this independents do not feel
comfortable republicans do not feel
comfortable mainstream liberals many
don't feel comfortable they feel like
they can't speak up and they can't speak
out and they can't just you know go to a
ball game or go to a restaurant or
decide what kind of product they want
without having to fear that they are
going to be judged
and castigated that's a terrible thing
for the country it means that we have
nothing in common anymore
i mean it's been it's been a long time
since we could even pretend that we had
the american flag in common half the
country thinks the american flag stands
for oppression apparently
so what exactly is going to hold us
together as things become more and more
political
things get worse and worse the answer is
not politics the answer
is community connection the answer is
church the answer is getting to know
your neighbors and having conversations
with your neighbors but all of this
has been banned the local authoritarians
don't want you to know your neighbor
in fact if you get to know your neighbor
and your neighbor happens to be a
republican they will cancel you
they will go after you for having the
temerity to have a conversation with
that person
this is the culture that we now occupy
and it's a culture that we're going to
have to fight back against if we
actually wish to preserve the country
moving forward into the future
unfortunately too many people don't want
to preserve the country this way
which is the reason why you are seeing
that big tech is about to be brought in
before house democrats and they're going
to grill top executives
at facebook google and twitter as
democrats take fresh aim at the tech
giant
for failing to crack down on dangerous
political falsehoods and disinformation
the idea here again from house democrats
being that if you allow people to speak
freely in ways we disagree with you're
making the country worse no you know
what makes the country worse
the idea that we don't all get to have
our opinion and then have conversation
about those opinions
lest we grant credence to the evil among
us
that is not treating your fellow
american as a fellow american and
treating your fellow american as an
enemy
and that's the direction in which we are
moving alrighty well on that depressing
note
we will see you here next week i hope
you have a wonderful weekend also we'll
be back here later today with an
additional hour of the ben shapiro show
first
you cannot forget to end your week by
watching the andrew clavin show drew is
back every friday he's got an exciting
evening planned for you so head on over
to dailywire.com this evening at 7 pm
eastern and tune in also remember to
download the ben shapiro show sunday
special
very special episode this sunday like
saved by the bell except with gina
carano
where gina carano is going to discuss
everything that's been going down for
the past couple of weeks
check that out over the weekend we have
a lot of great weekend content for you
and i'll see you back here on monday i'm
ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
colton haas executive
producer jeremy boring our supervising
producers are mathis glover and robert
sterling
production manager pavel wydowsky our
associate producers are rebecca doyle
and savannah dominguez
the show is edited by adam's high events
audio is mixed by mike coromina
hair and makeup is by fabiola christina
production assistant jessica kranz
the ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright 2021.
hey everybody this is andrew clavin host
of the andrew clavin show
you know some people are depressed
because the republic is collapsing the
end of days is approaching
and the moons turn to blood but on the
andrew clavin show that's where the fun
just gets started
so come on over to the andrew clavin
show and laugh your way through the fall
of the republic with me
andrew clavin